I run a five man team two men down what
does that mean he's missing two guys oh
it's okay so if I'm an team so what it's
supposed to be seven now five words it's
a five man team now there's only three
we don't know wouldn't know okay either
way we figure that he's undermanned sure
we know that much sure okay undermanned
team five-man team two Minda I'm not
meeting performance expectations no
sport coming from my command do you see
a way out other than just getting after
it I know you also talk about blaming
yourself in taking extreme ownership
because the people above you may have
different information that leads to
prioritize different areas however when
I question things like why we don't have
enough people working in different zones
when clearly there's an imbalance in
zones to the point customers notice or
it makes it difficult for colleagues to
do their jobs
then I'm deemed argumentative and that I
don't have the best intentions this was
this was with the manager that is in
charge of in charge of business and I
would think understands my perspective
more we're supposed to have a culture of
feedback but he isn't receptive I'm not
the only one who said that about him as
well this all needs to meet to me this
all leads me to think that I must just
be fake and go through the motions but
that disgusts me mm-hmm
yeah so what do we do here how do we
take ownership of this how do you take
ownership of your boss not listening to
you not hearing what you're saying well
the way you take ownership of that isn't
to say my boss doesn't listen and
doesn't understand the way to take
ownership of that is to say that I'm not
a I'm not doing a good job of getting my
information to my boss I'm not doing a
good job of convincing my boss I'm not
doing a good job of influencing my boss
boss so you can either be mad about that
or you can change your approach step one
we're going back to this again today
um build a relationship with that person
hmm now there's a chance that that
disgust shield there is right I've
talked about that before I've literally
said and I had great relationships with
people that I had like a visceral hatred
for I still had a good relationship with
him and work
it's very well with them if it disgusts
you and you can't do that
then there's other jobs right where you
have to interact with other people you
know he could be like a long-haul truck
driver hmm you can be a technical writer
you know where you just look at the
information and turn it into words you
can be a lab technician we don't have to
interact with a lot of different people
and that's cool um there's a lot of jobs
out there that require very little human
interaction that's fine because if you
think you're gonna go through life only
working with people that you get along
with you're wrong that's not gonna
happen especially if you want to run
teams and you want to lead and you have
to learn how to get over the fact that
you might have to work with people that
you don't like and by the way on top of
that if they know that you don't like
them that is not gonna make your job
easier in its kind I'm not gonna make
your life better in fact it's gonna make
your life more miserable the people that
I had visceral hatred for that that I
worked for it wasn't that bad because at
least they thought I liked them and and
I acted like it and they liked me so
it's like okay it's a little painful but
you know what it's pretty low impact and
as opposed to like head-to-head conflict
every single day and by the way when you
have head-to-head conflict every day
you're miserable
you're gonna advance slower you're gonna
have less control over your fate you're
not gonna get promoted and but on top of
all you're gonna get assigned the
crappiest possible jobs because your
boss doesn't like you and he likes that
other guy over there so he's gonna get
the easy job you know right he's gonna
get go you go save the princess Jocko go
slay the dragon right and of course you
know I prefer to slay a dragon it's
never been the princess but that's what
I'm saying like you want to get along
with this person want to play the long
game you can play the long game and
here's the deal when you play the long
game
if the person sucks as bad as you say
they do they'll end up making their own
bed and having to lie in it and they'll
end up working for you now also make
sure that you come to the table with
solutions not just complaints and
problems right you can see that this
guy's talking about
we don't have enough guys and I you need
his square of these zones what's your
solution to problems yeah and what's
really smart to do then you got to be a
little bit careful this but what can be
very smart to do is okay if you can
solve the problem with your own internal
assets just go and execute on it and
solve it
you know if you use your own internal
assets to solve a problem make the make
the change make it happen implement it
and you go to the boss and say hey this
is what we did there was this problem on
our zones or whatever mm-hmm the cool
yeah we we made this adjustment I took
two guys from this blah blah blah I
moved them around and now here's where
we're at we're getting better you know
results you have to be careful cuz you
can say that in a such a way that you're
thrown in your boss's face right you can
absolutely do that now even though you
were trying to build a relationship and
trying to help the mission you still end
up with an adversarial relationship with
your boss and now things go negative
against so you've got to be careful when
you do this you can also just present
the idea and present the solution be
like hey boss here's what I want to do
which is that's once you've got the
relationship trust built up that doesn't
there then you can't just go present a
broad present a solution of how you're
gonna do it's not gonna let you do it
cuz he doesn't trust you
he's got an adversarial relationship
with you you see where this is yeah you
see how this works yeah another thing he
says here he says uh he says I would
think the manage this was a manner that
is in charge of the business and I would
think he understands my perspective more
right so here we go
if you want to take ownership of things
and how you and you look at your boss
and say he doesn't blame my perspective
or doesn't understand my perspective
that's his fault mm-hmm you know the way
I look at that if you don't understand
my perspective as my boss it's my fault
mmm that means I'm not explaining to you
means I'm not giving you enough
information means I'm not convinced you
means I'm not building relationships
that you can see my perspective that's
what that is
so don't blame the boss step up your
game build the relationship teach him
the perspective and win and I'll tell
you one more little thing on this from a
to get away from the discussed mindset
mmm-hmm
because I understand that you know the
one one good way to get away from the
discussed mindset is to get into the
game mindset the game like this is a
game mmm and this guy that I don't like
I'm gonna become best friends with them
watch yeah be like okay oh you don't
like this guy cool watch yeah watch this
that's how it's gonna go and you're
gonna have fun with it are you gonna try
and win the game
yeah which is good sure that
understanding perspective I think that's
every day almost every day kind of thing
where okay so my wife we're on our way
to the park this is today by the way and
she's like oh it she said it's the zoo
parks there's one you can go straight
there's one you can make a right then
you make another left is there it's two
parks I don't know which one we're going
to I don't really mind which one we go
to so she's like yeah let's let's go to
the other one right and she mentions
this I don't know which even one is the
other one but whatever I'll follow your
directions so he said okay make her said
she goes stay in this Lane she doesn't
motion though she goes stay in this Lane
something okay and we're gonna stay in
this Lane she goes okay turn here but
then so she's not like pointing like
turn here it's like cuz there's a turn
right here then there's one like right
here you know turn here can apply to
like a bunch of stuff but in her mind is
super clear you know so if I would have
got mad or actually I can see how people
can get frustrated right there right
so if I would express myself you're not
being more clear boom now we're we're
relation yeah because I didn't in my
mind I'm like I can't read your mind a
sleighing bed when he leaves got a funny
story he was there on night visions in a
Humvee he's telling the driver he's in
the vehicle commander seat which is the
basically the path the front passengers
yeah and he's he's pointing he's going
hey turn here here here yeah and and the
guy just like keeps driving and he goes
bro are you doing and the guys like I
can't see you cuz we have night-vision
goggles on you have no peripheral vision
he said I can't see your fingers and
leaves echo sorry
because what you do propyl call is right
turn 30 meters or right right in turn
500 meters right turn 100 meters right
turn coming up a right turn boom and
that way the person can do it yeah but
Lafe was pointing but the guy couldn't
see yeah but there's this very similar
to your wife who's not pointing yeah she
wasn't pointing at the time
well here's the thing do anything this
is Jamie up I I'm not gonna take too
long in this one but the way girls take
your time we're over here the way girls
female females girls take do you
remember the last time you talked about
you generalize females go ahead at your
peril go ahead no it wasn't at my peril
because that that was the same thing but
it was the joint of Ice King yeah
exactly it's the same thing thank you no
one rule bike no Jew bike it's no
harassed you know someone drew you on a
try Sena animated legija was very
separate than the point but it was good
there was also some there was also some
pretty non-working bicycles that were
drawn correct yeah and I dig it and this
by no means says you know the
superiority or inferiority of any of the
sexes at all I'm just saying there's
daddy done girls and guys interpret and
give directions in completely different
ways because of how they how their brain
formulates like like directions so girls
kind of requires real generally speaking
girls require like land run Jordan B
Peterson back on the car caught this
okay I want to see if your director so
girls they they prefer like landmarks
and you know you know like the voice on
the thing like she'll be so they can
wait you mean the Siri voice Siri voice
yeah whatever whatever yeah I mean those
can help guys too or whatever did that
that navigation voice wasn't part of
this study so I should mention the voice
but they're vapor for like landmarks
like maker right interesting yet yeah
when when you're flying a jet plane sure
like an f-18 yeah which which I have
done a backseat ride and an f-18 before
but the voice that talks to you is a
female voice and and I was told that
it's because it relaxes it gets the
attention of and then kind of relaxes of
the pilots so it says like like when I
was flying and I don't know why
it wasn't like we were gonna die but at
all like I'm not stressed at all but the
thing would say warning it was a girl's
portion take warning warning altitude
altitude yeah and yeah so they say it's
relaxing a little bit yeah I could dig
it you know typically if my wife is
giving me directions it's not relaxing
I'm not stressful but it's not relaxing
so where were you going with this the
girl that you said was gonna be saying
it's it's dangerous to do the directions
thing the navigation thing with your
wife or your girlfriend or with a girl
with a girl thing like if you let's say
you and a girl in whatever capacity is
sitting next to you and you guys are you
know how like when we were looking for
the hotel yeah we're both sort of
looking for the hotel you know and we're
both kind of navigating and then I
failed then you just jumped me you don't
remember that you actually debriefed me
you're like hey when it was time when I
failed math you were just like I got
this here right turn coming up 500
meters right turn 200 meters yeah right
turn 100 meters rent turn right turn
right tune okay get in the right hand
lane and you were just like cool yeah
yes so easy so consider that type of
situation before you took over consider
that situation when you we were both
trying to navigate if you do that with a
girl you you are more likely to run into
problems because of this they in turn
right know what this isn't they
interpret and give directions in
different ways because the brain works
different they require like landmarks
got kind of guide them like okay make a
right at this make a left at this okay
that helps sure but it's more what a
guys go off of they build a map in their
head so if they're like okay like if
they looked at a map they'd be like okay
they'd have a better understanding okay
so sure I can make a right at the at the
building or whatever but when they make
a right they're like okay I made that
right so here I am physically oriented
you know and they kind of make sense of
that way more than the girls do I'm not
saying it's like one is black one is
white I'm seeing one does there's one
one does more tendency
yeah it's more than ten the tendency
because it's how your mind works okay
this is just the stuff I didn't do the
study I anyway I wanted to address this
with echo on social media can address it
to echo I'm out I will say this in
I'll believe the study I sure will cuz I
haven't been the other one is if you
have it if you listen all the podcasts
echo also said that girls cannot draw
offhand a functional bicycle correct and
he got a lot he got a lot of attempts
yeah and he did get one person that put
a gift - gift for animated give an
animated gif of echo himself riding a
tricycle yeah it was pretty awesome yeah
again beside the point but it was very
very awesome I don't even have any idea
what the point of anything that we've
said in the last few minutes and I don't
even want you to trying to we're talking
about miscommunication like I can't read
your mind you got a community you know
like you don't understand my perspective
you supposed to understand kind of thing
you know god yes yes true man so you got
to be clear is what I'm saying like how
you were we were finding that steak
place or hotel or whatever else a good
steak yes